jamais votre métier bien sûr vous avez
la terre d'une part ensuite vous
connaissez pas mal de gens
les gens qui viennent soit l'enterrement
soit autre et vous votre mort vous y
avez pensé
[Applaudissements]
oh là là
tout de suite quoi
vous êtes sensible à la mort des autres
[Applaudissements]
c'est
on n'est pas censé le faire voir vous
êtes croyant non
je pensais que après la mort
[Applaudissements]
je pense rien on verra bien
penser après déjà quelque chose
peut-être déjà quelque chose pour moi je
crois en moi c'était déjà une bonne
chose
si je travaille pas je mange pas vous
aimez la vie
[Applaudissements]
si j'aimerais pas la vie je serai pas
ici
[Musique]